the mission of
the umih's technology team the ldd has contributed to the
development of the
artificial intelligence eco-system in quebec
and canada
this is done in two different ways
in the first place we help
companies to innovate by introducing
the  artificial intelligence in the
products and solutions it
develops secondly we are creating
training programs in
machine learning to train
a new generation of experts who
will be able to contribute to industrial projects
apart from these two mandates
team members  eddy 20% of their time to
their own research projects in
collaboration with members of
academic and industrial communities
if you are passionate about
machine learning is deep
and want to have an impact on
all sectors of the  economy
come join us we are
hiring